You know what the fastest,
most efficient way to download
a piece of content is?
Not downloading it at all.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and when it comes to networking
performance, properly caching
your network data is one of the
most fundamental performance
wins that you can create.
At its core, reading
data from your device
will always be faster
than reading the same data
from your network connection.
And if you consider
that that piece of data
will be used multiple times,
it makes a lot of sense
to fetch it from the network
and then store it on the device
so that future requests don't
have to re-download the file.
But a slight problem
here-- you see, by default,
caching of HTTP
responses is disabled
for Android applications.
Pretty much everything you're
requesting in your app right now
is just dropped on the
floor after it's been fetched.
Turning caching on means
using the HTTP response
cache class, which allows
you to define a location
on the device as
physical file storage
as well as a max size
for the cache to be.
Now, once enabled, all HTTP
responses for your application
will be cached on
the file system.
And, yes, this does apply to
APIs, like a URL connection
and HTTP URL connections and all
the other fancy code snippets
that you copy-paste from
Stack Overflow examples.
And don't forget that
this also applies
to any HTTP request made
from libraries that you've
bundled into your application.
Now, it's worth pointing out
that with HTTP response cache,
data is evicted from
the device in two ways.
Number one, if the cache fills up,
then the system will delete
the oldest unused files to make
room for the new
ones, and number two,
files will be removed according
to their cache control header
information included
with the server response.
See, for HTTP 1.1
standards the server
will pass a flag down with
your requested data that
hints to the device how
long the information should
be cached for.
So, if the server says something
like, cache it for three days,
then the device will keep the file
around for three days before evicting it.
Or, if the server
says don't cache,
well, the file won't be
cached on the device at all.
Basically, HTTP response
cache puts all the control
of how to cache content in
the hands of the server,
assuming that it knows best what
types of data you're requesting
and how the device
should use it,
which is completely fine for
simple networking situations
or if you somehow
control the server
and have the ability to
set caching explicitly
for each data type.
But beyond that, you can get
into some really big trouble,
especially if you don't
control the server.
For instance,what if the server
never sets caching duration,
and nothing ever gets
cached on your device,
or what if the caching
values are in conflict
with the physical
resources of the device,
like a mis-estimating how much
free space there is to cache,
or what if your
client is trying to be
adaptive to the needs of
high latency environments
and actually tries
to modify the way
it's caching due to
those environments,
but the server won't let it because it
assumes you're on a 4G network?
Basically, any of
these advanced situations
requires you to punt
on HTTP response cache,
and instead brew your own
caching solution
which includes two
things-- number one,
writing your own
manager to cache
and fetch resources from disk
on demand, and, number two,
creating your own caching
policy based on the type of data
and the state of
the device itself.
Now, writing your own disk
cache can be a bit of a pain.
So unless you need
something custom,
it's probably a better idea
to steal the DiskLRUCache.java
implementation from
the Android source
and re-purpose it for your needs.
One of our sample code packages
has already done that for you,
if you're willing
to take a look.
Now, probably more complex is defining
a policy for what types of caching
to do for what types of assets
you are grabbing from the server.
See, thumbnails need
to be cached less often
than high-resolution
images, and other things,
like server pings, probably
shouldn't be cached at all.
And you might want
to keep around
server responses that describe
UI data for a much longer duration.
The truth is that this is
all exceptionally complex,
and thankfully, there's
libraries out there
to help make it easier.
Grabbing the Volley
or okHTTP libraries
will put you on a good start
to a more stable networking
implementation, although you
have to fiddle with the source
code a little bit to get it to
call your custom caching logic.
And, by the way, the
image library Picasso
comes built in with
custom image cache
management on your behalf.
Now, if you're not sure
how caching or lack thereof
is impacting your
application, make sure
you check out the
Networking Monitor tool
inside of Android Studio.
It offers a nice
visual representation
of the types of inbound and outbound
requests that are happening.
If you're seeing some
requests for content
occur that should
be cached instead,
it might be a good sign that
you should be digging deeper,
which is why I like to
use AT&T's ARO tool.
It basically lets you
do exactly that,
dig deeper with each
network request,
even checking out what
types of network header data
has been sent to the device.
But caching your data
is just the start.
That's why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
and don't forget to join
our Google+ community for
tips from other developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.